Some people think hospitals are the most dangerous
places on earth, more people die inside them
than anywhere else.
When people say things like that, they are
technically right and may get fooled by what’s
known as selection bias.
A selection bias occurs when we look at information
that it is not fully representative of the
data intended to be studied.
As a result of the biased sample, we then
draw a false conclusion.
One story that explains the bias perhaps better
than any other is that of Abraham Wald.
Wald was a brilliant mathematician, who, after
the Nazis persecuted him and his family as
Jews in Austria, fled to the United States
in 1938.
During World War II, Wald was invited to become
a member of the Statistical Research Group,
an elite think tank to aid the American war
effort against Nazi Germany.
One day the US Air Force came to Wald and
his colleagues with a problem.
Many of their planes got shot down due to
a lack of armor.
The officers presented Wald with data for
all the aircrafts that made it back from their
mission.
The planes had lots of holes on the body and
wings but less below the engines.
The officers then asked the mathematicians
to compute the optimal protection by concentrating
the armor where the planes were getting hit
the most.
After studying the problem, Wald suggested
something unexpected.
The armor, he said, doesn’t go where the
bullet holes are.
It goes where the bullet holes aren’t.
The officers didn’t understand, because
they were looking at a biased sample.
Wald wasn’t.
He realized that to get representative data
to analyze, he needed to include the missing
holes, the missing planes, the missing information.
The reason planes were coming back with fewer
hits to the engine is that planes that got
hit in the engine weren’t coming back, he
explained.
But selection bias isn’t just the result
of missing information.
The simpson paradox is a phenomenon in which
a trend appears in groups of data but then
when the groups are combined, disappears.
It shows the importance of really understanding
the data we select for analysis.
One famous example came from students applying
to the University of California, Berkeley
in 1973.
The data showed that males applying were more
likely to be accepted than females.
People thought that the institution was discriminating
against women.
When researchers dug deeper into the data
they found out that men had applied to less
competitive departments with higher rates
of admission.
Women chose more competitive departments with
fewer available spots.
After correcting for this detail the data
showed a significant bias in favor of women
- not men.
Planes that were shot in the engines were
not analyzed.
Women in Berkley weren’t discriminated against,
but instead picked more competitive classes.
People that die in hospitals are often already
sick when they are admitted.
What are your thoughts?
Is selection bias corrupting your decision
making?
And if it’s fooling you, how about the people
behind the “research” you see being published
in popular media?
Did they really make sure they selected an
unbiased fully representative sample?
Share your thoughts in the comments below!
And if you still don’t quite understand
it, here is a simple challenge to experience
it first hand!
Go out of your house, knock at the doors of
your next 10 neighbors, and ask those who
open if they are afraid of strangers.
After you are done, report your findings in
the comments below and explain to us: what
can your research tell us about your community?
Anything?
This video was brought to you by Brilliant.org.
Brilliant is a learning platform we really
like, because it’s playful, interactive
and perhaps the best way to learn math and
computer science.
Brilliant challenges you with problems that
you then have to solve interactively, an approach
that allows you to master complex concepts
in 15 minutes a day.
Whether it’s introduction to probability,
applied probability, statistics, or random
variables - when it comes to mathematical
thinking Brilliant has all sorts of simulations
for you.
You’ll learn how to think in numbers, relationships,
stats and distributions — all essential
skills for life!
To try everything Brilliant has to offer — free
— for a full 30 days, visit brilliant.org/sprouts
or click on the link in the description.
The first 200 of you will get 20% off Brilliant's
annual premium subscription.
If you like how we explain complicated ideas
in simple cartoon animation, you can support
us!
Visit patreon.com/sprouts!
Just visit us, learn how it works and what’s
in it for you.
We hope to see you there.
And if you are a parent or educator, check
out our website sproutsschools.com.
There you can find this and other video lessons,
additional resources and classroom activities.